que s'est-il passé la nuit dernière dans
la communauté d'Emmaüs de Chinon un
incendie a ravagé un entrepôt de meubles
très compagnons évacués et après le choc
l'interrogation car ce sinistre vient
s'ajouter à d'autres incidents récents
Léa Turquie
l'air est encore chargé de cendres lundi
soir à Chinon vers 22h l'un des
entrepôts d'Emmaüs prend feu 13
compagnons sont sur place
sur le mur et le volet de ma chambre et
tout ça puis on s'est penché tout de
suite voir on a vu que l'incendie il y
avait des flammes qui faisaient à peu
près 8 mètres de haut à tout de suite
j'ai demandé au gars de sortir j'ai
frappé à toutes les portes de sortir
pour les mettre en sécurité ensuite j'ai
appelé les pompiers qui sont arrivés
très vite
l'alerté lancée le feu est finalement
éteint aux alentours d'une heure et
demie du matin tous les meubles une
partie des vêtements et les jeux pour
enfants sont partis en fumée
une chaleur intense qui fit sur même les
carreaux de la salle de vente le
bâtiment
voisiner la sécurité des gens et puis la
deuxième lieu ben on va nettoyer déjà la
partie qu'on a le droit c'est-à-dire un
côté magasin on peut rien faire puisque
là faut reconstruire le bâtiment complet
ça va que dès le moment on pourra ouvrir
comment je sais pas mais on va voir
les causes de l'incendie sont toujours
inconnus une enquête est ouverte pour en
déterminer l'origine ce dernier
événement conclut en moi difficile pour
Emmaüs qui a connu quatre acte de
vandalisme à Chinon depuis début octobre